c
[Musique]
la parole est un autre collègue martin
de sidrac pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre qui est
présent parmi nous et je voudrais
commencer très simplement par vous poser
une première petite question
connaissez-vous chanteloup-les-vignes
monsieur le premier ministre c'est une
ville de 10000 habitants à l'ouest de
paris dans les yvelines qui est
aujourd'hui meurtrie par les
affrontements de samedi entre des
criminels et des policiers ces
affrontements ente entraîné l'incendié
d'un équipement collectif champions est
une ville française comme menthe béziers
où brest et qui aujourd'hui pansent
leurs plaies et se bat au quotidien
reconquérir mètre carré par mètre carré
chaque morceau de son leur territoire
républicain que des criminels souhaite
voir disloqué car lorsqu'on brûle nos
villes qu'on attaque nos policiers ou
qu'on menace nos élus c'est la
république on brûle qu'on attaque et
qu'on menace monsieur le premier
ministre et pour bien combattre ce mal
il faut bien le nommer et il faut le
comprendre relativiser ce qui s'est
passé en qualifiant les agresseurs
d'imbéciles fut en effet une erreur
monsieur le premier ministre ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que ses agresseurs
très organisés défendent
l'extraterritorialité de leur espace il
rejette les lois de la république
il refuse toute autorité venue de l'état
est il interdit ça la république de
s'occuper de leurs affaires ils font
session monsieur le premier ministre
c'est cela que vous devez nommé et
combattre avec la plus grande fermeté
monsieur le premier ministre comment
envisagez-vous de rétablir l'autorité de
l'état autorité que vous devez à nos
concitoyens qu'ils soient dans les
yvelines où ailleurs dans la en france
merci pour vous répondre
la parole le père monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice la première partie
de votre question m'est adressée
personnellement il s'agit de savoir si
je connais chanteloup les vignes
la réponse est oui j'ai la chance de
connaître cette commune des yvelines se
connaît la maire de chanteloup les
vignes je me suis rendu en tant que
premier ministre j'ai visité un certain
nombre de quartiers le commissariat j'ai
pu rencontrer ce qui pour le compte des
services de l'état et en tant qu'élus
locaux gèrent cette commune et essaie
d'apporter les réponses les plus
adaptées à une situation dont nous
savons qu'elle est dans cette ville
difficile donc la réponse est oui
vous évoquez ensuite les événements qui
sont survenus samedi dernier en début de
soirée l'attak le guet-apens contre les
forces de police l' incendie criminel
sur l'équipement culturel de
chanteloup-les-vignes fois sur à des
équipements culturels de
chanteloup-les-vignes vous me dites que
pour bien traiter les questions il faut
savoir les nommer vous faites se faisant
référence
la qualification que j'ai pu avoir de
petite bande d'imbéciles comme je suis
comme vous attacher à la parole publique
et aussi aux positions qui sont prises
par les élus locaux je me permets de
vous faire remarquer madame la sénatrice
que le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines que vous
connaissez comme moi que vous respectez
qu'à moi a pour sa part utilisé le terme
crétin je ne sais pas s'il est plus
léger plus infamant plus responsable
plus dur que petite bande d'imbéciles je
ne sais pas si le terme racaille ou
sauvageons qui a été utilisée qui ont
été utilisés la vérité la vérité
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
vérité mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est que je crois que nous
pourrions tous nous entendre sur le fait
que ceux qui comptent plus que le choix
dans le champ lexical que nous faisons
c'est la réalité des faits et la réalité
des réponses la réalité des réponses
madame la sénatrice est la suivante nous
souhaitons mettre tout en oeuvre
pour que l'ordre soit rétabli lorsqu'il
est dérangé et pour ce faire nous
essayons d'attaquer le problème de
toutes les façons possibles lorsque nous
doublons madame la sénatrice le budget
de l'anru nous ne le faisons pas pour le
plaisir simplement de doubler un budget
nous le faisons parce que à l'ecoute des
élus locaux nous savons que les
opérations de rénovation urbaine sont
des éléments puissants de réponse à ce
problème et je le sais parce que
j'écoute madame la maire de chanteloup
les vignes
parce que j'écoute le cas échéant le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines et parce que madame la
sénatrice
j'ai été maire du havre et je sais ce
que c'est que l'anru et je sais ce que
c'est que les opérations de rénovation
urbaine et je sais ce que c'est que les
violences urbaines
par expérience voilà je préfère le dire
clairement et simplement je ne parle pas
de façon théorique je parle parce que je
sais que les opérations de rénovation
urbaine permettent d'apporter n'ont pas
toutes les réponses mais une partie des
réponses que ces quartiers existe c'est
la même exactement la même logique que
je poursuis lorsque avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement
nous essayons d'augmenter les effectifs
de la police nationale
dix mille effectifs supplémentaires dans
la police nationale
dans l'ensemble du quinquennat qui a
commencé en 2007 pourquoi pas pour le
plaisir d'augmenter les effectifs parce
que malheureusement ces effectifs font
défaut et que nous savons que pour
apporter une réponse crédible
nous devons améliorer le niveau de
présence des forces de l'ordre
c'est ce que le ministre de l'intérieur
le secrétaire d'état et c'est de faire
lorsque nous des doublons les classes de
cp
lorsque nous essayons de faire en sorte
que l'éducation fonctionne mieux y
compris dans les zones et surtout dans
les zones dites sensibles
c'est exactement la même logique nous
essayons d'aborder cette question par
tous les bouts si vous me permettez
cette expression
nous sommes parfaitement conscients de
la difficulté nous avons évoqué avec
madame la maire de chanteloup les vignes
ses difficultés
j'observe et c'est intéressant et je
sais que vous y serez sensible puisque
vous êtes attachés comme moi à ce que
disent les élus locaux
j'observe qu'elle a parfaitement pointé
le fait que
nous venons perturber des trafics de
stupéfiants à chanteloup les vignes
comme dans d'autres villes et que
lorsque l'on perturbe ses trafics
lorsque l'on vient briser des habitudes
et des habitudes néfastes et criminel eh
bien ça se voit ça crée forcément des
turbulences et nous devons les affronter
ne pas nous horrifier de ces turbulences
elles sont la conséquence d'une action
résolue et nous allons poursuivre cette
action car la lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants la préparation du futur dans
ses quartiers dans ces villes est un des
objectifs du gouvernement et je suis sûr
que vous le partagez la parole et a le
truc collègue alain fouché pour le
groupe les indépendants sur cher
collègue vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur mes chers
collègues certains individus font des
concours de kate apens contre les
services de secours les forces de
l'ordre ces concours de l'âge se propage
depuis plusieurs jours relayé par les
réseaux sociaux
la réponse apportée doit être la fermeté
la nouvelle mode de ces criminels et de
se filmer pendant leurs attaques contre
les forces de l'ordre
désoeuvrés ou protégeant des trafics
ils oublient bien vite la chance qu'ils
ont de vivre dans un pays qui respecte
l'état de droit et qu'eux-mêmes ont
intérêt à respecter
rien ne saurait justifier ces atteintes
à l'ordre public à la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et de ceux qui les protègent
au quotidien les gendarmes les policiers
les pompiers auxquels je veux rendre
hommage
les tensions dans les quartiers
défavorisés sont en recrudescence
voilà plus de trente ans que les
gouvernements successifs tente d'en
venir à bout
sans y parvenir vraiment il semble
qu'une trentaine d'individus étaient
impliqués dans le guet-apens de
chanteloup les vignes
seuls deux interpellations ont eu lieu à
ce jour
l'obtiennent ville comme ailleurs cette
situation n'est pas acceptable
la réponse judiciaire doit être à la
hauteur des infractions commises
monsieur le ministre je sais que vous
vous êtes rendus sur les lieux hier
matin
ma question est la suivante que comptez
vous faire pour que les forces de
l'ordre disposent de moyens plus
importants nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de leur mission
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
christophe castaner monsieur minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur fouché
vous avez évoqué 30 ans d'action avec
des succès des réussites en matière de
politique de la ville mais aussi avec
des échecs et une situation qui dans de
nombreux quartiers ne s'est pas
améliorée tant en matière sociale
d'espérance dont en matière de lutte
contre une sorte de déterminisme social
et d'assises à sion à résidence dans ces
quartiers qu'en matière d'insécurité et
de violence face à nos forces
c'est la raison pour laquelle hier matin
quand je me suis rendu à
chanteloup-les-vignes j'ai proposé à la
garde des sceaux j'ai proposé au
ministre en charge du logement de la
politique de la ville de m'accompagner
tout simplement parce que c'est trop
conquête républicaine que nous devons
conduire dans ces quartiers ne relève
pas que de la seule police elles
relèvent évidemment de la police mais
elle relève de l'ensemble de l'action
qui est porté sur ces territoires et
notre première volonté a été d'être à
côté de madame la maire de chanteloup
les vignes qui porte un projet ambitieux
pour sa commune et qui se bat chaque
jour avec les associations et dans le
cas présent ce sont les activités de ces
associations qui ont été mises en cause
quand nous allons rencontrer les parents
les mamans de ce quartier c'est ce
qu'elle nous ont dit monsieur le
sénateur ce qui s'est passé est
inacceptable le comportement de ces
voyous est inacceptable et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut
effectivement des sanctions exemplaires
d'ores et déjà deux personnes ont été
interpellées ont été mis à disposition
de la justice la qualification
criminelle a été retenue pour
l'instruction de cette affaire
l'enquêté se poursuit et je suis
convaincu qu'il y aura d'autres
personnes interpellées mais au-delà de
cela je voudrais redire comme vous
l'avez dit tout mon soutient à cet
engagement puissant fort manifeste
courageux
de nos forces de sécurité intérieure la
police mais aussi de nos sapeurs
pompiers qui étaient protégés par la
police au moment de ces incendies
deuxième élément je vais vous dire ma
détermination à renforcer plus encore
les moyens de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure je présentais cette nuit le
budget de la sécurité qui a augmenté de
1 milliard d'euros depuis 2010 est pour
justement donner des moyens aux forces
de sécurité intérieure et nous aurons
l'occasion dans cet hémicycle d'en
débattre
pour donner plus encore de moyens à nos
forces et les soutenir je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue laurence
cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique avez la
parole
si monsieur le président la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage instauré par décret
et qui est entré en vigueur le 1er
novembre est un véritable cataclysme 850
mille chômeurs et chômeuses on voir
leurs indemnités baissé de 20% et 200000
vont être privés de toute indemnité
ce sont plus d'un million de personnes
qui vont être frappés de plein fouet
croyez-vous sérieusement adam la
ministre cette demandeuse d'emploi qui a
interpellé le président macron à la
réunion en lui disant il n'y a pas de
travail comment fait-on avec 790 euros
par mois va voir sa situation améliorée
c'est tout le contraire qui va se
produire et vous le savez et ce sont des
secteurs aux contrats discontinue qui
vont être davantage impacté
l'hôtellerie-restauration spectacle et
pas de nettoyage pour ne prendre que
quelques exemples votre réforme va
enfoncer la tête dans l'eau des plus
précaires c'est une réforme sexistes et
anti jeunes les syndicats et les
associations de priver d'emploi sont
vent debout debout contre une telle
réforme et appelle très justement à
manifester le 30 novembre et le 5
décembre les agents de pôle emploi se
disait aussi choqué par ces nouvelles
règles
ma question est simple madame la
ministre avec cette réforme inique
vous comptez faire une économie de 4,5
milliards d'euros en trois ans pourquoi
ne pas vous attaquer aux allègements de
cotisations patronales qui de 2013 à
2019 ont atteint les 26 milliards
d'euros
on vous répondre la parole est à madame
la ministre du travail
l'âme peu d'écho vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice laurence cohen je ne reconnais
pas du tout la réforme de l'assurance
chômage dans ce que vous dites
d'abord je voudrais dire que il faut pas
nier les faits d'abord notre politique
en matière de marché du travail commence
à porter des fruits et nous sommes
modestes il en reste beaucoup à faire
dans le département du val de marne par
exemple c'est le chômage est passé de
8,3 à 7,4 pour cent
ça c'est le fruit de travail
systématique sur la formation sur
l'apprentissage les ordonnances et
l'assurance chômage va venir
l'assurance chômage vous n'avez pas du
tout parlé c'est un triptyque pourquoi
nous modifions les règles de l'assurance
chômage parce que le contexte a changé
aujourd'hui nous avons créé un demi
million d'emplois en france nous
secteurs économiques avec les aides du
gouvernement et de et deuxièmement il ya
beaucoup d'emplois vacants j'étais à la
réunion avec le président de la
république je peux vous dire qu'il ya
énormément d'emplois avait quand même à
la réunion où évidemment il ya un taux
de chômage qui est inacceptable qu est
très difficile c'est pour ça que cette
réforme c'est un triptyque 1 sur les
employeurs nous visons - une précarité
pour ça nous pénalisons les employeurs
qui a buzzé contrats courts car le
premier sujet de la pauvreté c'est le
chômage
la vraie trappe à la provôté c'est le
chômage et la précarité qui instaurait
par des contrats beaucoup trop court
neuf embauches sur dix sont contraintes
ricou nous nous battons contre eux ce ça
avec le bonus malus avec le ctd eu vous
ne l'avez pas fait avant personne ne l'a
fait avant nous nous y attaquer le
deuxième sujet c'est l'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi de façon inédite
un million de demandeurs d'emploi va
avoir un accompagnement beaucoup plus
important beaucoup plus pro actif comme
le font très bien les pays scandinaves
comme nous l'avons testé avec des
demandeurs d'emploi à nice et dans
d'autres agences pour l'emploi car je
vais beaucoup dans les agences pôle
emploi
je peux vous dire que c'est très fort
mal vient des problèmes du terrain et
des solutions qu'on amène au problème du
terrain et l'accompagnement il va avoir
des effets le troisième sujet sur le
sujet de l'indemnisation le sujet de
l'indemnisation
il faut revenir à la normale la normale
c'est ce que les partenaires sociaux
avaient négocié avant crise quand il ya
de l'emploi
quand il ya une dynamique en même temps
que du chômage il faut à la fois
protéger et inciter au retour à l'emploi
c'est ce que nous faisons et c'est ce
que nous faisons pour l'emploi et contre
la précarité
adam cohen madame la ministre mon propos
de convainc que vous même parce que la
réalité quand vous nous parler des
chiffres du val de marne ce sont les
radiations c'est ça la réalité et votre
réforme madame la ministre qu'est ce que
c'est c'est une machine à faire exploser
la précarité et la pauvreté plus de 9
millions de pauvres dans notre pays
aujourd'hui vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est suffisant et inacceptable alors
pourquoi vous allez encore grossir le
rang
vous avez décidé de supprimer
l'observatoire national de la pauvreté
mais madame la ministre casser le
thermomètre ne fait pas baisser la
fièvre
votre politique ce n'était des peaux
plus généreuse quand il s'agit de servir
les plus aisés qui voient leurs revenus
augmenter de 1% et il faut que vous
arrêtiez avec cette politique et il faut
vous arrêtiez de faire de la com
les gens attendent autre chose de
mesures ils seront dans la rue
nombreuses et nombreux et on sera avec
eux si la parole est à notre collègue
claude bérit-debat pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues punition catastrophe
sociale trappe à pauvreté
autant de mots entendus pour qualifier
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage et
je le fais mien sans réserve pour votre
gouvernement le cap est clair à droite
toute cette réforme imposée par décret
et pour reprendre les mots de laurent
berger c'est une réforme les plus durs
socialement qui s'est opérée ces 25
dernières années avec les nouvelles
conditions draconiennes d'accès au droit
on estime qu'en 2020 sur les 2,6
millions de personnes qui auraient
bénéficié des aménités avec l'ancien
système
près de 10% ne pourra ouvrir aucun droit
et 23 % des bénéficiaires verront leurs
droits rognés pour une question purement
comptable pire au 1er avril 2020 avec
votre nouveau mode de calcul 1,4 million
de demandeurs d'emploi verront leurs
indemnités baisser drastiquement les
personnes ayant un rythme de travail
fractionné déjà précaires seront les
premiers impactés madame la ministre
vous faites des économies sur le dos des
plus fragiles vous culpabiliser les
chômeurs vous en fait des boucs
émissaires sans leur donner les moyens
de retrouver
un véritable emploi alors arrêter cette
politique de régression et de
ségrégation sociale
mettez en place des mesures ambitieuses
pour résorber le chômage
lutter contre la précarité et
accompagner réellement les chômeurs vers
l'emploi pour vous répondre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur claude bérit débat
vous parlez avec des grands mots moi je
vais vous parler avec des faits nos
politiques
elles ont de l'effet est ce que vous
savez que c'est en dordogne car + 76 %
d'apprentis au premier semestre
et ça c'est notre politique et ça va
continuer car nous allons sortir plus
encore de chômeurs qu'ils puissent
retrouver un emploi depuis deux ans nous
avons permis à trois cent mille
demandeurs d'emploi de retrouver la
travaille ça ça plus pourquoi parce que
nous faisons un investissement sans
précédent et aucun gouvernement l'a fait
avant dans tout ce qui aide les
demandeurs d'emploi l'année prochaine il
y aura neuf cent soixante mille
demandeurs d'emploi en formation est
jeune et il demandant le point
information nous aurons aussi un v6 sont
plus d'un milliard d'euros dans les dix
insertion par l'économique dans le
budget qui vous sera présenté dans
quelques semaines et j'espère bien vous
le vôtre et puisque vous comme nous vous
souhaitez l'insertion des plus
vénérables lui n'est inemployable mais
il faut des marchepieds pour les aider
en ce qui concerne les indemnisations du
chômage
moi je m'étonne que sur ses bancs
certains pensent que le travail c'est
moins bien que le chômage nous sommes
inscrits en faux aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis factuel un demandeur
sur plan un demandeur d'emploi sur cinq
un demandeur d'emploi sur cinq gagne
plus au chômage qu'au travail
c'est cela dont l'indemnité baisse au
début il garde le même capital de droit
ils pourront être divisé plus longtemps
s'ils ne trouvent pas d'emploi n'ai eu
aucune déviation de leur capital de
droit mais un sac à mais tous les
experts l'ont confirmé ce n'est pas la
faute des gens c'est les règles qu'on
fait les partenaires sociaux ils n'ont
pas vu l'angle mort que sacré ils n'ont
pas fait exprès mais maintenant il faut
le corriger
le travail doit les payer plus que le
chômage nous croyons à l'insertion à la
formation au travail c'est la société
qu'on veut faire et donc il est injuste
que quelqu'un aujourd'hui et 150 % de
son salaire au chômage alors que les
autres et ça reste très protecteur tout
le monde
entre 65 et 85 % de son salaire oui pour
le travail précarité oui pour
l'insertion ta parole est maintenant de
notre collègue gilbert luc deux villages
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre le 31 août
dernier à villeurbanne
un jeune homme a été tué par un migrant
afghan aux motivations mais dans délire
religieux et troubles psychiatriques
graves
ce drame atroce illustre la nécessité de
soins psychiatriques adaptés pour tous y
compris les migrants
aujourd'hui vous annoncer les mesures
visant à durcir nos conditions d'accueil
parmi celles ci il y à l'instauration du
délai de carence pour les demandeurs
d'asile pour bénéficier de la protection
universelle maladie avec cette mesure ne
prenez vous pas un double risque d'abord
un risque sanitaire
nous parlons de personne qui souffre
parfois de maladies infectueuses faut-il
attendre que leur pathologie s'aggrave
pour qu'elle soit prise en charge en
durcissant l'accès aux soins
ne faites-vous pas peser un risque
sanitaire pour tous ensuite un risque
juridique
la france a ratifié la directive accueil
de l'union européenne
son article 19 précise que les états
membres doivent assurer les soins
médicaux urgents et les traitements des
maladies psychiatriques des demandeurs
d'asile monsieur le premier ministre
cette nature est elle conforme aux
engagements européens de la france
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame agnès buzyn avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur de vinasse la ligne que nous
avons choisie est unie de responsabilité
d'humanité nous avons tenu bon sur le
panier de soins nécessaires grâce à un
rapport effectué par l'igas et 10 g f
qui a eu comme mission de réfléchir à
l'efficience de nos politiques publiques
en matière d'accès aux soins et ce
rapport dit clairement qu'il ne faut pas
restreindre le panier de soins c'est ce
que nous faisons
par contre ce rapport met en évidence un
certain nombre d'abus ou de dévoiement
du système et nous avons pris deux
mesures
l'une qui permet aux demandeurs d'asile
d'accéder à la pum ans avec le même
délai de carence de trois mois que ceux
qui s'appliquent aux ressortissants
français qui arrivent sur le territoire
après avoir vécu à l'étranger ou aux
étrangers arrivés en situation régulière
et qui n'ont pas d'emploi qui accèdent à
la puma uniquement au bout de trois mois
d'autres c'est simplement une
harmonisation de l'accès à la pum ans et
dans le délai de trois mois
ces étrangers malades ont évidemment
accès aux soins urgents qui comprennent
les soins évidemment urgents vitaux mais
également tous les soins anti contre les
infections
en ce qui concerne les maladies
psychiatriques nous sommes absolument
persuadés que le psychodrame à des
migrants est un vrai sujet donc nous
mettons en place en parallèle de ces
mesures de lutte contre la fraude
nous mettons en place des mesures qui
vont vers ces publics de façon à avoir
un
un parcours du primo arrivants un
parcours de santé qui fait un bilan qui
permet de bien orienter des patients
notamment de prendre en charge les
pathologies liées à la migration que ce
soit des pathologies infectieuses
ou des pathologies psychiatriques et
donc il y aura un renforcement du budget
dépasse des permanences d'accès aux
soins de santé
il y aura également une expérimentation
qui est mené à rennes qui va être
déployé pour voir si ces migrants
peuvent être soignées en médecine de
ville et donc nous avons une mesure à la
fois de rationalisation de l'accès à l'a
pu m'en met en parallèle une action qui
vint vers ces populations pour les
prendre en charge efficacement dès le
premier jour sur les pathologies pour
lequel il ya un réel besoin je vous
remets ce merci monsieur gélinas
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président oui même la
ministre lutter contre les abus je
dirais lutter contre tous les abus qui
peut être content mais là en
l'occurrence vous prenez des mesures
envers les plus démunis en pénalisant
l'ensemble des migrants et en nous
faisant prendre un risque sanitaire en
manière santé faut rester simple
la prévention il vaut mieux prévenir que
guérir et c'est encore là la meilleure
des économies merci la parole dès
maintenant à notre collègue anne marie
bertrand pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre
le public présent dans cet hémicycle ne
peut ni applaudir ni conspué les
orateurs la raison est simple les élus
ne légifère pas sous la menace
c'est un principe essentiel dans une
démocratie
depuis le vote par cette assemblée d'une
loi interdisant le port de signes
religieux lors des sorties scolaires
nombreux sont les sénateurs qui comme
moi ont reçu des mails menaçants allant
jusqu'à espérer notre mort la liste des
cent soixante trois sénateurs ayant voté
cette loi qualifiée par certaines et je
cite de scélérate et jeté en pâture
le groupe facebook
parle même de sénateurs nazis et il
invite ses membres à communiquer les
lieux de résidence et les photos de
parlementaires qui ont voté ce texte les
intimidations sont explicites d'autres
collègues
jacqueline eustache brinio auteurs de la
ppl qui mène un combat primordial pour
la laïcité a été contrainte face à la
violence des attaques reçu de se
constituer partie civile
je tiens à lui apporter tout mon soutien
un texte démocratiquement votée par une
assemblée des parlementaires traque est
menacée et monsieur le ministre on ne
vous a pas entendu on ne vous a pas
entendu dénoncer ce qui constitue une
atteinte grave à l'exercice d'une
démocratie sereine
pourquoi ce silence pourquoi vous être
question le ministre de l'intérieur à ce
titre quelles mesures comptez vous
prendre pour mettre fin à ses tentatives
d'intimidation est devant nous nous en
inquiéter je vous remercie pour vos
réponses parole comme cheminée de
l'intérieur
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice
je crois que sur ce sujet nous devons
tous nous dresser c'est celui de la
liberté du débat public qui est
particulièrement cher dans un hémicycle
comme celui du sénat et qui est
consubstantiel même à l'engagement
politique de chaque ligne de chacun
d'entre vous et de chacune de chacun
d'entre nous et donc je crois qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire de polémiquer et
j'entends votre interpellation qu'est ce
que j'ai fait qu'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait immédiatement la saisine de la
plateforme pharos parce que j'ai été
saisi par votre collègue jacqueline
eustache brinio et j'ai fait ce que je
fais à chaque fois un signalement au
procureur est une expression politique
la plus forte possible pour dénoncer ces
actes d'intimidation totalement
inacceptable et je le fais devant vous
comme je lé fais madame la sénatrice de
façon quasi systématique quand je suis
alerté directement auprès des
parlementaires concernés au 1er
septembre nous avions enregistré 240 4
actes de violence ou de malveillance à
l'égard d'élus ou de parlementaires 212
en cadres du mouvement des gilet jaune
32 dans le cadre du ceta est
systématiquement nous les avons tous
ensemble condamné quels que soient les
désaccords que nous pouvons avoir et que
nous pouvons exprimer dans cet hémicycle
mais c'est la liberté même du débat dans
cet hémicycle qui fait que vous êtes
protégé dans votre prise de parole et
nous vous devons madame la sénatrice
ainsi qu'à chacune et chacun ici la
protection de la police ou de la
gendarmerie chaque fois que nécessaire
et des poursuites sur la protection j'ai
donné instruction précise à chaque
préfet que pour que chaque parlementaire
qui sollicite l'appui le contrôle
l'assistance sur la mise en sécurité de
sa permanence parlementaire par exemple
puissent être accompagnés et je le redis
ici au sénat et puis il ya les
poursuites judiciaires mais madame la
garde des sceaux a signé ce matin même
une circulaire à l'ensemble des
procureurs pour que sur ce sujet là
comme sur toutes les menaces qui sont
faites aux élus parlementaires ou élus
locaux
il y est systématiquement une volonté de
recherche de responsabilité et de
sanction pour qu' aucun de ces
comportements totalement scandaleux ne
puisse menacer la liberté d'expression
et la liberté de vote de chacun de nous
de la république
[Musique]